be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so with luke cage's Netflix series
premiering in the next three days or so
what am I do here is take to the next
couple of days and kind of provide some
emphasis on Luke Cage of course I do
want to have a discussion just later to
the end of this week on how to kill Luke
Cage and I'm pretty sure they'll cover
that in the TV show but I think it'd be
a cool to sketching a have here on my
channel too but I want to kick this off
by running over the four issue inaugural
series of Power Man and Iron Fist by
David Walker now what's really funny
about this is it comes out as part of
all-new all-different marvel but again
like most of Marvel's titles it's not
all new and it's not all different but
David Walker does take certain liberties
and he does a very good job at it but
historically speaking both Luke Cage and
Danny Rand have a very lengthy history
and Marvel Comics whereas I have a video
on Luke Cage explain I have a video on
Danny Rand iron fist explain and you're
welcome to check both of those out
you'll find them down in the description
but to kind of provide a little bit of
backstory here Luke Cage was created as
a byproduct of exploitation I'm sorry
blaxploitation in the 1970s and
blaxploitation was a cultural phenomenon
you know during the 1970s that was
designed to create content geared
towards African Americans and really
only African Americans they were African
American films that were directed and
starred African Americans produced by
African Americans but the problem is
blaxploitation was not a long-term trend
much like a lot of things that come and
go in society blaxploitation more or
less went the way of the dodo and the
result was that the reason for
individuals to read Luke Cage the reason
for readers to tap into Luke Cage was
basically gone because there wasn't
really a way to make him a compelling
character at least at the time anyway
when you were faced with such popular
characters and teams like spider-man
Thor Iron Man the x-men The Avengers
Captain America so on and so forth and
so as time progressed Luke Cage as
comics began to slump in sales now
around this time Danny ran the iron fist
was created and iron fist suffered from
much the same problem except the Danny
Rand was designed to be a way to tap
into the Hollywood concept of Americans
learning kung fu' just because of how
popular kung fu was at the time male
most notably with regards to Bruce Lee
and Chuck Norris and there are different
forms of martial arts in and
Hollywood films by Danny Rand was much
the same way because of the fact that
popularity in kung-fu movies began to
fade Danny Rand went with it and so it
got to the point where neither of these
characters could hold their own title
and so in truth I would go as far as to
say that Marvel caught lightning in a
bottle and the reason why is because
under the writing of Mary Jo Duffy
Marvel rolled both characters over into
a singular series called Power Man and
Iron Fist now this basically took the
premise of luke cage's character as
being a hero for hire which is to say a
person who would solve people's problems
for payment and transformed it into a
concept for both himself and Danny Rand
and so instead of being a superhero team
in the traditional sense
they were basically detectives and they
would go around using their street-level
contacts and they would solve
street-level crimes you never see them
save the world or anything like that it
was just small-time stuff but because of
the comedy that Mary Jo Duffy
threw into the series it resonated with
a lot of fans and Power Man and Iron
Fist proved itself to be an extremely
popular series running for I think
around 125 issues but the issue is a
Marvel was gearing towards darker
content especially you know in 1971
after the death of Gwen Stacy it was
time to start moving in a more realistic
territory with stories and so under the
direction of editor-in-chief Jim shooter
Mary Jo Duffy was basically removed from
the title because she wasn't doing what
she was told more or less she wasn't
making the stories dark like Marvel
wanted her to they replaced her with
curb music but he did the exact same
thing he kept the story's light-hearted
and fun and fans loved it but in the end
under the writing of Christopher priest
Danny Rand was killed off and the story
was effectively canceled now following
this Luke Cage just kind of fell down
the rabbit hole
to be quite frank he hit every weird
story and every bad piece of writing on
the way to the bottom and it was kind of
a shame to see because he was such a
prominent character he was given solo
series which in turn were canceled that
led to more solo series and those solo
series were canceled and it happened
over and over and over and over again it
wasn't until the mid 2010 's when Marvel
launched The Mighty Avengers the second
iteration that Luke Cage got his own
Avengers team and this is where he
really stood out because by this point
there had been you know another run of
power Man and Iron Fist but it paled in
comparison to the run of Mary Joe Duffy
and in the end
you know having Luke Cage running his
own team proved to be wildly successful
but what David Walker does here is he
seems to ignore all that stuff there
doesn't really seem to be any reference
whatsoever to Luke Cage his time leaving
the new of injured or leading the Mighty
Avengers instead it looks as though he
simply just picks up from Power Man and
Iron Fist vol 2 and the reason why I say
that is because once we you know as we
get into this of course Luke Cage and
and Danny Rand are hanging out and the
question everybody's asking the question
that that his wife Jessica Jones is
asking is whether or not you know Heroes
for Hire it's coming back again then
Luke Cage his answer is no and this is
really just kind of David Walker playing
with sort of setting up the stage and
and you know injecting a little bit of
humor here but for those of you guys who
don't know you know Luke Cage and
Jessica Jones got together during Brian
Michael Bendis the series alias which
was the original appearance the first
appearance of Jessica Jones as part of
Marvel max which was models
adult-oriented lineup and that's where
you saw you know the introduction of the
purple man that was largely what the
Jessica Jones Netflix series was based
off of but you know by the time that
series came to an end Luke Cage and
Jessica Jones had become an item I don't
remember whether or not they actually
got married although I believe they did
of course we know that they produced a
child and Jessica Jones had kind of been
in the background of Marvel Comics ever
since but she's still very much uh very
I guess an important person in Luke Cage
is life and she you know that's that's
shown here in David Walker's writing but
with Danny ran he's the comedic half
Luke Cage is kind of the muscle and a
serious tone Danny rands the funny side
and Danny ran of course is making jokes
you know tell Jessica Jones you know I
said what's up different things like
Cabo what David Walker does and he cause
it brings us back a little bit to the
history saying that you know iron fist
and Luke Cage have a history together
but this again is where I say he seems
to be ignoring a lot of the Mighty
Avengers stuff because he directly
references their time together as Heroes
for Hire but he doesn't reference
anything else but what happens is the
two of them are traveling to to the
local prison in order to pick up a girl
named Jenny at least I believe it's
pronounced Jenny s j JH II and in IE I
think it is I can't remember exactly how
you spell it it's written in the comics
but the fact remains here that she had
recently been released from prison this
is yet again David Walker referencing
Power Man and Iron Fist because Jimmy
was a she was a secretary basically
Jenny Rose was a secretary for the
Heroes for Hire organization but she had
fallen into a relationship with a with a
crime boss or not relate from boss with
a small-time criminal then the result
was that he had beat her and she ended
up killing him and when she was at least
argue that she was framed you know of
course the guy had been killed with his
own gun and her fingerprints were on it
and so she was sentenced to prison but
Danny Rand and in Luke 8 you're here to
welcome her back to the world with a
free and to get her acclimated to her
regular life but what the end up doing
is in of transitioning to a place called
Excelsior diner of course named after
the infamous catchphrase of Stan Lee and
Judy tells them that there is a necklace
that belonged to her grandmother that
had been taken by a man named Lincoln
Lonnie Lincoln now Lonnie Lincoln is a
long-standing villain and Marvel Comics
he's actually a very low-level villain
he's very very street-level he's a guy
named tombstone he just runs a criminal
empire he's a less he's a less stellar
version of kingpin if that makes any
sense to you guys
but in the end Lonnie Bader I'm sorry uh
Jimmy basically makes the case that her
her necklace had been taken as payment
for money that her former boyfriend owed
and the issue is that with him being
dead this necklace has been taken and
she wants to see if Luke Cage and iron
fist will get that necklace back for her
so this is basically David Walker kind
of setting up you know the reuniting of
iron fist and an Luke Cage you know as a
team working together once again but
again we also got a few funny moments
here in there you know for example Luke
8 starts saying things like
fiddle-faddle instead of swearing we're
swearing is a well-known aspect of his
character and we we kind of get a
flashback to both Jessica Jones and Luke
8 spending time with her daughter and
she's just kind of cussing up a storm
and so Jessica says that Luke needs to
watch his language around their daughter
because her daughter's basically
learning bad words from him and so he
instead of you know using swear words
he's just saying things like
fiddle-faddle and knick-knack
patty-whack and it's kind of nonsensical
but what is up happening is Luke Cage
and Danny ran travel to the to the
office or I guess to the home of Lonnie
Lincoln and what they say is you know of
course they don't mention Ginny by name
in order to keep her keep it protected
but they simply offer the case that
Ginny's basically said that you know
Lonnie Lincoln is in possession of a
necklace that belongs to her as payment
for you know debts that her her dead
boyfriend
and Luke Cage and Danny Rand are there
to get the necklace back now what we
learn is that according to Lonnie
himself the necklace was never taken as
a debt that was owed instead the
necklace was acquired through blood well
as legitimate means as you can get when
you're part of a criminal empire but the
fact remains that with Lonnie seeming to
indicate that he's taken offense to the
fact that Luke Cage is calling him a
liar and Luke Cage is calling him a
thief in the end he sticks all of his
men on both Luke Cage and iron fists now
of course you're able to take them all
out it's really not a great big huge
scenario here there's a little bit of
battle and in and out and of course we
see luke cage's signature statement of
sweet Christmas which I really hope they
have in the Netflix series and I really
hope you guys put that down in the
comments section but um in the end you
know this is really just this is just
kind of showing us you know the two of
them getting into some nonsense kind of
getting into skirmishes different things
like that but the end up getting you
know once they defeat all the guys Lani
basically says that hey look like that
necklace is not just a regular necklace
that necklace has power now we're not
initially told what power this necklace
has or what value what significance the
necklace has we simply just pick up with
Danny Rand and Luke Cage once they leave
and they travel back to the sisters of
mercy house which is basically a halfway
house for those individuals who were
released from prison and trying to make
their way back into the back into normal
society you guys will have noticed that
in the Netflix series has been featured
several times
I think night nurses paid several visits
to the Sisters of Mercy house but what
ends up happening here is a junior
basically cries a little bit and says
hey thank you so much I'm glad you
brought this back but then we actually
learn that there are some ulterior
motives here the first is we switch to
Loni Lincoln who says that the necklace
is actually the supersoul stone now
again we don't really know what that is
right now we'll find out here in the
next little bit but we also learned that
Ginny had been tricking iron fists and
Luke Cage but she had duped them into
acquiring the necklace for her and this
necklace had been acquired for Ginny on
behalf of a girl named Mariah Dillard
now Mariah Dillard is a character that
will appear in the Netflix series which
I'm actually really excited about and I
hope they show her original appearance
as a crime boss because the reason why
is when she first showed up in Marvel
Comics as a criminal and an enemy of
Luke Cage and iron fist what she was
doing and one of the most genius schemes
that I've ever heard of in my life but
what she was doing is she basically
stolen ambulance she was impersonating
an ambulance driver and then she began
driving around picking up the bodies of
the deceased
and then robbing them of their valuables
and then just dropping their bodies off
like I mean I know it's a terrible thing
to do but it's actually not
unintelligent it's actually pretty smart
it's it's uh I don't mean to say you
guys should do that you know but but any
of it you know it's one of those we have
circumstances what we do here is we pick
up you know with dish number two and
we're this your number two we have of
course Lonnie Lincoln kind of freaking
out we have Henry Reaper I'm sorry we
have a guy named Reaper and it is
basically everybody learning that Lonnie
Lincoln had lost this necklace but
they're being in for by Lonnie Lincoln
are the very least by his henchmen that
they want that he wants the necklace
back and to take care of Iron Man I'm
sorry take Frey to take care of Luke
Cage and iron fist by any means
necessary and so it's essentially an SOS
going out to everybody to do whatever
they need to do to take out you know the
Heroes for Hire now this is simply just
designed to show us the various villains
that will likely see the Heroes for Hire
going against over the course of the
publication history under the writing of
David Walker and however long his tenure
on this title may be but again this is
this isn't necessarily a huge deal it
shows a little bit of criminal but for
the most part the story largely focuses
on Ginny and Mariah what we do is we
pick up with Ginny and Mariah themselves
and they're just kind of talking to
their various contacts are being
informed that that Lonnie and Lincoln's
looking for the necklace so they're kind
of being given a heads up more or less
but we end up transitioning back to the
Excelsior diner and we join uh you know
Luke Cage and iron fist now a funny
thing about this is he asks you know
iron fists why he's wearing that mask to
the superhero diner because I mean
there's street-level criminals but I'm
sorry the street-level heroes most
everybody knows who they are but the
mask isn't really necessary you know
it's just one of those funny things you
know that that's it's basically David
Walker kind of drawing attention to the
idea of heroes wearing masks despite the
fact that everybody knows who they are
new or different things like that like
when Batman you know wears this costume
while he's talking to Dick Grayson
different things like that but but the
fact remains here that iron fist makes
the case that they should get back
together now Luke Cage is adamantly
against this and this this makes sense
for Luke Cage he's got a family you know
he's got a wife he's got a daughter he
has those individuals to look out for
you know despite the fact that he has
unbreakable skin it doesn't mean that he
cannot be killed and so in order to keep
him safe he's simply doing
as a one-time favor for Ginny and then
after that there are he's basically
gonna call it quits but the case that
that Luke here I'm sorry the case that
Iron Fist makes is that there's been a
long history of Heroes for Hire you know
they have had huge roles and this is
again where David Walker is really just
tapping into the Power Man and Iron Fist
history and leaving everything out what
he basically says you know I guess what
you know iron fist does is he points to
character is like you know like like
howleen he points the characters like
misty night you know characters who had
taken up the mantle of Heroes for Hire
in their stead albeit with Luke Cage and
iron fist coming in periodically and in
the argument of iron fist what are you
saying is you know Luke Cage can
somebody just leave that legacy gone he
can't leave that legacy vacated people
have to stand up for it but they have
something to stand for and so what we
end up doing here is we basically run
into this sort of warriors kind of
scenario and what I mean is that for
those of you guys who saw the film
warriors it was one of those one of
those movies that was you know rooted in
80's culture things like that but the
worries was the gang that was framed for
the murder of a Grand Poobah you know
boss and it was basically all the games
that were trying to track them down and
they ran into each gang on the way back
- you know - on the way to prove their
innocence with Luke Cage and iron fist
it's much the same way they're being
tracked down by all these different
gangs and they're they're fighting him
off as best they can which they've you
know largely been successful really able
to do but then they're encountered by
gorilla man
now gorilla man is a guy who again is a
very street-level criminal along with
black tarantula as you guys notice they
probably have really really goofy names
and it's designed to be that way Power
Man and Iron Fist is not designed to be
a super serious title this is designed
to be something you know enjoyable fun
and a little bit nonsensical here and
there but gorilla Man is a guy with
super-strength and he uses it for that
very purpose he's really just designed
to be kind of like the antithesis to
Luke Cage on the street level and so
woth is you know wall gorilla Man and
tarantula man and while you know Iron
Fist and Luke Cage while they all get
into a major skirmish they're actually
washed by Spider Woman uh Jessica drew
and they're washed by gwen stacy and
this is the funny thing here
because they're just watching all this
go down they're just watching things
happen and this is one of the greatest
things about this story this is why I
love the story so much because one of
the you know with with Luke Cage and
Iron Fist being a street-level team
they're working together it's still very
well known they're extremely well known
in the superhero community and so you
know Jessica drew and spider-gwen know
they can handle themselves it's just wow
are they really back together again like
it really seems like they're back
together again and that's that's
basically all they're doing that is
looking at everything in ortho they're
back together again that's cool you know
they're kind of taking videos and
different things like that but it's just
one of those funny moments that's kind
of being injected into this but again
you know iron fist and Luke Cage more or
less just duke it out with gorilla man
and they're able to hold a run you know
it's not really a super in-depth
discussion here but what is happening is
of course again as we continue this as
we continue our story we end up with
Luke Cage and Iron Fist traveling back
to the sisters of redemption halfway
house and they want to ask questions the
question is why is lani and Lincoln in
such hot pursuit of this necklace you
know if he wanted you know if if it was
stolen it if it was simply a stolen
necklace he would just let it go it
really wouldn't be worth it but the
necklace must have some kind of meaning
or some kind of value if they're
searching after it that hard and so what
we end up doing is we transition back to
Ginny and Mariah and what we learn is
that an order for the super super small
stone to be used the person has to both
H I guess some sort of tribal marks on
their body and then utter an incantation
in order to activate the stone and
that's exactly what happens after
learning about how it works
Ginny begins to I guess she draws
various you know what what appeared to
be tattoos she has various artifacts
drawn on her arms and all over her body
and she utters an incantation and that
her body mutates into some variation or
I guess maybe seems to absorb this super
soul stone we don't really know exactly
what it means but that brings it into
this video guys um let me know down in
the comments section what you guys think
about Power Man and Iron Fist it's a
little weird to be honest you know it's
a little it's kind of a strange
direction to take but again you know the
story's designed to be this way the
story's designed to deal with
street-level heroes getting into weird
things you know things have just seems
strange that normal superheroes just
wouldn't take the time to look
so anyway let me know what you guys
think make sure you guys are the like
button if you enjoyed this video hit the
sub button to become part of the rob4
and yeah I will catch you guys later
peace
[Music]